qui s'y frotte s'y pique
à paris dans le quartier de la gare
d'austerlitz j les jeunes et forces de
l'ordre se font face
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les grandes artères de la capitale
des manifestants venus en nombre pour
dénoncer les nouvelles règles sanitaires
aujourd'hui un combat essentiel qui est
rentré en plus depuis cet été et depuis
toutes ces mesures qui est contre la
vaccination obligatoire contre le
passeport qui était sanitaire qui est
devenu vaccinale et là c'est la liberté
de tous les citoyens qui est attaqué
dans le cortège est également une figure
du mouvement des gis les jeunes toujours
aussi remonté contre le gouvernement des
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
tiki tiki en parle aujourd'hui le
constat et les suivants on ne demande
pas la population française qu'est ce
qu'on attend tous les sens combien leur
demander un non mais après on doit se
taire et ça les français ne veulent plus
aujourd'hui
côté des revendications la défense des
libertés menacées selon les manifestants
par l'entrée en vigueur du pass
vaccinale depuis le 24 janvier dernier
il est désormais obligatoire pour aller
au restaurant au spectacle ou encore
prendre le train ce week end les
protestations ont pris des allures de
combat politique florian philippot le
président des patriotes avaient appelé à
se rassembler près de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
certains manifestants demandent aux
politiques de montrer l'exemple est ce
que nos politiques sont vaccinés si ceux
qui prétendent l'être bien qu'ils
passent directement devant une
commission août je sais pas quel comment
on peut appeler ça pour les tester pour
vérifier son but si j'en viens été
injecté on n'a pas les épaules pour se
présenter on a nommé aucun candidat donc
aujourd'hui on a que dans l'espérance
qu'il ya des candidats qui reprennent
leurs revendications parce que personne
peut ignorer tout ce que l'ensemble de
ses citoyens
ont réclamé ont revendiqué pendant trois
ans pour une autre manifestante croiser
ce samedi les choses doivent se régler
démocratiquement par les urnes et non
par la force l'élection présidentielle
est attendue de pied ferme le premier
tour de la présidentielle est fixée le
10 avril prochain le second tour deux
semaines plus tard